just as there's more to eddie brock than
meets the eye there's more to venom let
there be carnage than just the obvious
plot beats here's our guide to the
easter eggs winks and nods throughout
the off-the-wall venom sequel
for a journalist eddie brockshaw seems
to keep his information sources limited
nearly every time eddie is seen surfing
the web he's on the daily bugle website
shriek and detective patrick mulligan
seem to enjoy the print edition of the
same paper also worth noting these san
francisco-based characters are reading
the west coast edition of what is
apparently in sony's spider-man universe
a nationwide paper published in nyc for
those who have never picked up a
spider-man comic the daily bugle has
been around since marvel mystery comics
number 18 way back in 1941 and served as
a location for peter parker's first day
job starting with 1963's issue 2 of the
amazing spider-man over in the mcu the
latest daily bugle depiction as seen in
far from home is headed by a much more
visible jay jonah jameson seemingly
reimagined as an angry news program host
and less like the editor-in-chief of old
it's unclear if the mcu bugle has a
print edition but even across universes
one thing hasn't changed for jameson he
still thinks spider-man is a menace
which brings us to the mid-credits scene
in carnage when eddie and venom find
themselves in an unfamiliar place
watching what appears to be the mcu's
daily bugle report that reveals
spider-man's secret identity as we've
seen from the no way home trailer this
moment comes right after the events of
2019's spider-man far from home and sets
off the seemingly multiverse bending
plot machinations of the third tom
holland spidey film more importantly for
the immediate future of both spider-man
and venom jameson's reporting also seems
to turn venom's attention to peter
parker
at the beginning of carnage audiences
are taken back to 1996 when francis
barristan is being pried away from
cletus cassidy and relocated from the
horrific saint estes reform school to
the even more horrific ravencroft
institute for the criminally insane
placed under the care of dr camille
pazzo shriek endures decades of
isolation experimentation and cruelty at
ravencraft this is in keeping with
comics depictions of the dark gated
quasi prison even if some details have
changed most notable perhaps is that
pazzo is now in charge rather than the
kinder dr kafka of the comics in the
comics ravencraft is located in
westchester county new york rather than
the outskirts of san francisco it has
gained a reputation as a leading maximum
security holding place for superhumans
and appropriately enough is built on
land cursed by 15th century indigenous
tribes after serving as home to a
cannibalistic cult ravencraft is where
cletus is typically depicted as being
held and in the comics he first
encountered shriek there releasing the
villain to help him increase his body
count taking its cue from dc's arkham
asylum in marvel comics ravencraft has
essentially become shorthand for a place
supervillains are sent when it's time to
rest recharge and plan their next
inevitable escape
in case you can't tell from his
committed off-the-wall performance tom
hardy is really into playing eddie brock
so much so in fact that the intense
veteran actor is credited for the first
time as a writer on venom let there be
carnage even though he was more of a
talker than a writer writer kelly marcel
who penned both films and has a working
relationship with hardy that stretches
back nearly 20 years told empire about
hardy's participation in the creation of
the sequel this is new for him to get
credit it's not new for him to be this
involved he's absolutely 100 committed
to everything that he does
of the process she explained he doesn't
get a pen and write we spent months
breaking the story together on facetime
riffing on ideas seeing what worked
seeing what didn't then i took
everything we spoke about and holed up
somewhere for three months quietly
knocking out a script as for hardy's
love for the character marcel added he's
married to venom he loves this character
he's very involved in what he thinks
should happen
what really made you change your mind
[Music]
want to get real nerdy a trailer for
venom let there be carnage gave a
glimpse of detective mulligan reading
the daily bugle and then angrily
shutting the paper if you freeze frame
the image at just the right time and
look beyond the front page you can read
a headline that appears to say avengers
lose to nightmare as comic fans know
nightmare is the master of the
subconscious a fear lord who is hundreds
of years old and frequently crosses
dimensions often battling doctor strange
and the ancient one this is where things
potentially get very interesting
nightmare also has ties to morbius the
so-called living vampire that jared leto
will soon be portraying in another film
in sony's spider-man universe in the
comics nightmare once used morbius to
set a trap for strange allowing him to
take over the doctor's body and enter
the real world and leading to a wild
fight between morbius and nightmare as
dr strange that would be pretty amazing
to see in live action
a few hours before let there be carnage
officially hit theaters letto tweeted a
picture of the sequel poster along with
the vampiric message i can't wait to
sink my teeth into it what does all this
mean well there's a chance it could be a
hint that nightmare will become the
thanos of this particular crossover
serving as a central plot point that
could eventually link the sony universe
and the mcu or the headline could always
be referring to something else
there are a litany of literary
references throughout carnage citing
everything from don quixote to the bible
but most instrumental in uncovering the
plans of cletus cassidy might be a verse
he seems quite fond of scribbling venom
spots the following verse on the walls
of cassady's cell and then guides his
host's hands to recreate it and other
clues including the text to thee the
strife was given between the suffering
this verse seems to be drawn in the
middle of a sketch of the tree outside
saint esther's reform school where the
love struck duo once carved a heart on
the letters ck plus fb
in case you're not up on your lord byron
the quote is from his 1816 poem
prometheus which details the greek god
who gave fire to man leading to his
punishment
the passage could be a message to shriek
who has greatly suffered but who cassidy
sees as his soulmate
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]